salve youtubers e benvenuti ad una nuova
recensione prima di iniziarla come al
solito vorrei consigliarvi un canale e
il canale dei fuori di testa un trio
comico veramente spassosissimo che fa
video comici
per i pochi che non lo che non li
conoscono potete trovare il canale nelle
informazioni del video iscrivetevi
perché meritano davvero
detto questo iniziamo ma prima vorrei
ringraziarvi per l'enorme feedback che
mi avete dato nel video di metal gear
solid filantropi e dark resurrection
perché son contento sono veramente
contento perché non pensavo
vi sarebbero piaciute e diciamo non
pensavo che così tanta gente sarebbe
stata interessata a vedere questi due
piccoli capolavori quindi io son
contento e vi ringrazio anche da parte
loro probabilmente quindi grazie mille
magari posso farle più spesso queste
cose non così tanto spesso ma tant'è il
film che voglio recisi re oggi e deadly
pre in un film diretto da david prior
nel 1987 il film è un classico action
degli anni 80 90 con il classico sfondo
della guerra del vietnam
in quel periodo c'erano un sacco di film
che trattavano della guerra del vietnam
chi prima chi dopo tipo rambo nello
stesso anno sono usciti film come e full
metal jacket e good morning vietnam
per carità non voglio fare nessun
paragone era solo per farvelo sapere
e quindi vediamo quali sono i cinque
punti per cui questo film esilarante e
fastidioso allo stesso tempo più
fastidioso che esilarante
numero 5 la trama premessa la trama del
film tratta da una storia di gavin lyell
scritta nel 1924 chiamata the most
dangerous game ma come potete intuire
non ho niente a che fare con la trama
del film se non vagamente l'incipit in
poche parole un gruppo di marin barra
mercenari prendono a caso per strada
completamente a caso delle persone una
persona e la lasciano libera nei boschi
per poi cacciarla come se fosse un gioco
di caccia ma si scopre che il nostro
protagonista cioè la persona che loro
hanno rapito completamente a caso in un
quartiere a caso dell'america è buttato
dentro una foresta è un reduce del
vietnam
su 6 miliardi di persone sono riuscite a
prendere l'unico reduce del vietnam che
assomiglia un po sylvester stallone e un
po don wilson che fortuna due cose però
non mi sono chiare 1 perché diavolo lo
devono sfogliare lasciare con quei
imbarazzantissimo e pantaloni il cinema
che perché
2 la storia da cui tratta una trama del
film non era proprio così ce loro non è
che prendevano una persona a caso e la
caccia mano così è una cosa stupida da
mettere in una trama è un incipit pug
etico per fare un film pieno di
sparatorie ed esplosioni gettato lì che
faceva una trova del tipo una persona a
caso riesce in mezzo alla strada trova
un bazooka e distrugge la cittá fine ma
comunque anche se la trova il debole può
essere un gran bel film giusto
numero 4 recitazione il film inizia con
l'uccisione della prima vittima per
farti capire che loro fanno questo gioco
con persone completamente a caso si vede
questo tizio che scappa scappa scappa in
mezzo alla foresta ma quando riescono a
raggiungerlo per ucciderlo
guardate la sua reazione
non canai
[Musica]
cosa diavolo era quell'urlo allora
l'intonazione dell'orlo c'è ma
l'espressione facciale dove ma ragazzo
mio settore mobile sopracciglia su e giù
e non riesco a capire le emozioni che mi
vuoi trasmettere o mi ha chiesto per
morire aiutatemi che problema ci hai tu
sto per morire aiutami non vedi come
soffro
jimi va tutto bene a casa sto per morire
sono morti comunque tutto il film è
pieno
no che non ho i pochi dialoghi che ci
sono nel film sono recitati veramente
veramente da cani
però c'è una scena che mi ha fatto
morire dalle risate non parte
l'espressione facciale
friends enemies
flyer
[Musica]
questa scene spassosissima c'è lui che
mentre scappa incontrano persone gli
chiede amico nemico
ecco questa persona non appena gli
risponde amico all'istante senza nessuna
espressione facciale che tnt che ha già
capito che stavamo intendo anche se
effettivamente non stava mentendo gli
dice loro live
[Musica]
sei un bugiardo che io sono un robot
venuto dal futuro per ucciderti
non so perché ma ho dovuto stoppare il
film e reader per mezz'ora perché no non
ce la facevo
numero 3
sparate per la prima metà di film in cui
quando prendono il protagonista e lo
buttano nella foresta e lo inseguono
quindi volta che lo vedono praticamente
non sparano allora sono pieni di armi
ovunque granate pistole mitra e non
sparano mari poi lui li prende sempre
alle spalle sempre alle spalle di solo
si accorge di una beneamata cippa lippa
di niente prima mi son dimenticato in
una cosa come ha detto adesso per la
prima metà di film loro non sanno
neanche da che parte si sa lo cercano
per tutta la foresta e lui che li segue
gli uccide ma scappa c'è loro non sanno
neanche dove la foresta è immensa e di
poco fuori los angeles corri teneri
anche se hai quei pantaloncini che non
ti farebbero entrare neanche in una
macelleria ma comunque scarpa non lo non
scappa e non spiegano il perché ma
andiamo avanti tornando al discorso di
prima non sparano basta sparate avete le
acli casa ce l'avete a fare le armi se
non sparate modifico riesce a trovarselo
davanti lo colpisce con l'arma e poi la
butta perché perché in tutti i film
nazioni ci deve essere sempre quello che
vuole affrontare il protagonista a mani
nude come diavolo può finire secondo te
come
[Musica]
appunto e questo amico mio si chiama
figura di merda anche se devo dire che
il rametto che prende da per te non è lo
stesso che viene infilzato poi nella
cassa toracica perché quello che ci a
terra è abbastanza piccola da essere
quello che ti potrebbe riportare
indietro un chihuahua ma questi sono i
film squallidi film dove ogni cosa è
possibile anche che i tuoi [__] si
frantumino e cadono per terra per l'ho
capita fin troppo spesso purtroppo
numero due
immortale come ho detto prima nella
prima meta di il non sparano e anche il
corpo perché li tengono tutti per la
seconda metà di film nell'ultima
mezz'ora gli spara addosso detto ciò ci
sono delle scene in cui gli sparano con
un carro armato e non è che non lo
colpiscono lo colpiscono
[Musica]
e l'esplosione causata dal colpo del
carro armato è piuttosto piccolina a mio
dire e noi ovviamente ci si arrampica
sopra sgancia una grata la lascia dentro
chiude il loro ci accoglie the boom
gli sparano d'america ci sa fare
ci guardate l'agenda me che corre in
votando e una scena pietosa ma va bene
gli sparano dall'elicottero lui poi
ficca una granata nel mitre spara
l'elicottero ed esplode in questa
esplosione che sono che è un'altra
esplosione un'esplosione fatta su uno
sfondo nero che non ha nulla che vedere
con l'elicottero non ditemi che l'unico
modo per uccidere staccargli la testa
perché abbiamo già preso per il culo
abbastanza firme c'è una scena
addirittura in cui nella foresta sono in
quattro di fronte a lui a sparargli e
non a preti che lo si vede neanche i
colpi che vanno contro gli alberi o per
terra sperando che non escano scintille
dagli alberi ma comunque da nessuna
parte lui non viene neanche scalfito al
lobo dell'orecchio o all'unghia
dell'indice niente
eh sì ma non muore cosa c'è il lag
omg nube cheater voglio vedere giusto
per sapere no perché se fai un film con
sfondo la guerra del vietnam un attimo
di realismo cv o no no non è
obbligatorio ma un attimo di realismo ci
vuole no
numero uno le uccisioni in una parola
una delle prime uccisioni del film il
cose che non mi sarei mai io lo sapevo
che era il film bri anche prima di
guardarlo però detto ma vediamo le
decisioni saranno come quelli del rambo
turno dove sparano nel fumo vengono
colpiti e fanno tutte quelle mostra le
no proverò questa è una delle prime
uccisioni fatta dal protagonista ai
danni dei marines bordate
c'è manca soltanto il pubblico intorno
che un la six wives actionaid ma non
poteva come tutti gli altri
accoltellarlo tappargli la bocca per
soffocarlo qualcosa non lo so in
un'altra scena il film diventa un film
comico degli anni 40 con la classica
granata nei pantaloni
[Musica]
esattamente come ireland lui costruisce
delle trappole per uccidere i marin
[Musica]
le trappole ovviamente hanno una fisica
di una gravità tutta loro ma civile che
potrebbe essere benissimo messa nel film
mamma ho persona euro e funzionerebbe lo
stesso
[Musica]
adesso mi spieghi come meccanicamente
potrebbe un accordo a trascinare uno da
un piede sollevarle schiantano contro
delle spine comunque questo era il film
in pillole non vi ho fatto vedere tutte
le scene perchè ce ne sono un
quadrilione di miliardi e non potevo
farle tutte sulla recensione veniva
infinita e vi consiglio anzi gli
straconsigliato guardarlo questo film
perché per quanto fastidioso possa
essere in alcuni punti è veramente
divertente in altre quindi è anche per
questo che non l'ho messo nei somme di
zio good perché questo film aveva un
budget di lo so bene quanto ma un
piccolo budget chen aveva abbastanza
alto sarà sul suo mezzo milione di
dollari che è abbastanza per fare un
film d'azione rambo è costato molto meno
mi sembra o di più non mi ricordo devo
andare a controllare comunque guardatelo
con gli amici perché fa veramente
sbellicare e noi ci vediamo vi ringrazio
ancora per tutti gli iscritti tutti i
commenti tutti i complimenti e noi ci
vediamo ad una prossima recensione
ma come è finita qui non c'è nessuna
scena che potrebbe entrare negli annali
delle scene più squallide leaf in più
squallidi del mondo ma è ovvio
[Musica]
[Applauso]
all
[Musica]
salve sono il realismo del film volevo
chiedervi una cosa perché mi avete
mandato a [__] non so che l'ho già
fatta questa battuta ma mi dispiace non
posso non farla
[Musica]
un classico questa volta vi saluto per
davvero ripeto vi ringrazio per tutti
gli iscritti tutti i commenti tutti i
complimenti che mi fate e ci vediamo ad
una prossima recensione